i've got a transformation t
and when you apply t
the transformation t to some x in your
domain it is equivalent to multiplying
that x in your domain or that vector by
the matrix a
and let's say we know that the linear
transformation t can be
that's transformation matrix when you
put it in reduced row echelon form the
transformation matrix it is equal to
an n by n identity matrix or the n by n
identity matrix well this alone this
alone tells us a lot of things first of
all if when you put this in reduced row
echelon form you get a square identity
matrix that tells us that the original
matrix had to be n by n
and also tells us that t
is a mapping from rn
to
rn and we saw in the last video all of
these are conditions especially this one
especially this one right here for t to
be invertible
for t to be invertible so if we know
that this is true t is a linear
transformation it's the reduced row
echelon form of transformation matrix is
the identity matrix right there
we know that t
is invertible
invertible but let's remind ourselves
what it even means to be invertible to
be invertible
means
means that there exists
there exists some we used the word
function before but now we're talking
about transformations they're really the
same thing so let's say there exists
some transformation
let's call it t inverse
t inverse like that or t to the minus 1
such that
such
the composition of t inverse
t inverse with t is equal to the
identity transformation on your domain
the identity transformation on your
domain
and the composition of t
with t inverse
is equal to the identity transformation
on your
codomain on your codomain just like that
and just to remind you what this looks
like
let's draw our domains in codomain
our domain is rn
and our codomain is also rn so it's just
like that
codomain is also rn so if you take some
if you take some
vector in your domain apply the
transformation t you're going to go into
your codomain so that is t and then if
you apply the the t inverse after that
you're going to go back to that original
x
so this it says look you apply t and
then you apply t inverse you're just
going to get back to where you start
it's equivalent to the identity
transformation it's equivalent to the
identity transformation just like that
this is saying
if you start here in your codomain you
apply your inverse first you apply this
inverse transformation first then you
apply your transformation you're going
to go back to the same point in your
codomain so it's equivalent to the
identity transformation
in your codomain it just happens to be
in this case that the domain and the
codomain are the same set
r
n
now we know what a transformation uh
what it means to be invertible we know
what the conditions are for
invertibility so this begs the next
question is this we know that this guy's
is a linear transformation in fact
that's one of the conditions to be able
to represent it as a matrix or any
transformation that can be represented
as a matrix vector product is a linear
transformation so this guy is a linear
transformation but the question is is
is
t inverse
a linear transformation
a linear
transformation
and let's review what the two conditions
are that we need to have to be a linear
transformation so we know t is a linear
transformation so we know that if you
apply the transformation t to two
vectors let's say x
and y if we apply to the sum of those
two vectors it is equal to the
transformation of the first vector plus
the transformation of the second vector
that's one of the conditions or one
thing that we know is true for all
linear transformations and the second
thing we know for all linear that we
know is true for all linear
transformations is if we take the
transformation
of some scaled version of a vector in
our domain it is equal to
the scaling factor times the
transformation of the vector itself
these are both conditions for linear
transformations so let's see if we can
prove that both of these conditions hold
for t inverse
for this guy right here so to do this
let's just let's apply
let's do this little exercise right here
let's apply
t
let's take the composition of t with t
inverse
of
of two vectors a
plus b remember t inverse is a mapping
from your from your codomain to your
domain although they're both going to be
rn in this case but t inverse maps from
this set to that set but let's write it
up here t inverse is a mapping from
your codomain to your domain although it
looks identical just like that
okay so what is this going to be equal
to well we just said by definition your
inverse transfer of your inverse
transformation this is going to be equal
to the identity transformation on your
codomain
so assuming that these guys are members
of your codomain in this case rn this is
just going to be equal to
this is just going to be equal to a
plus b
this thing the composition of t with its
inverse by definition is just the
identity transformation on your codomain
so this is just whatever i put in here
if i put in an x here this would be an x
if i put in an apple here this would be
an apple it's going to be the identity
transformation now what is this equal to
what is this equal to
well i could use the same argument to
say that this
right here is a is equal to
the identity transformation applied to
a
and i'm not writing the identity
transformation i'm writing this but we
know that this is equivalent to the
identity transformation so we could say
that equivalent to the composition of t
with the inverse applied to a
and we could say that this
is the equivalent to the identity
transformation which we know is the same
thing as
t the composition of t with t inverse
applied to b
so we can rewrite this thing right here
we can rewrite this thing right here as
being equal to
these two the sum of these two things in
fact we don't even have to rewrite it we
can just write it equal to this
transformation is equal to this and
maybe an easier way for you to to
to i guess process it is we could write
this as t of
the t inverse of
a
plus b is equal to
t of the t inverse of a
plus
t of
the t inverse
of b
and this should you know that i don't
know which one your brain processes
easier but either of these when you when
you take the composition of t with t
inverse you're just going to be left
with an a plus b you take the
composition of t with t and versus
you're left with an a and you take the
composition of t with t inverse you're
just left with a b there so in either
case you get a plus b the vector a plus
you get when you evaluate either side of
this expression you'll get the vector a
plus the vector b
now what can we do
we know that t itself is a linear
transformation t is a linear
transformation and since t is a linear
transformation we know that t applied to
the sum of two vectors
t applied to the sum of two vectors is
equal to the sum of the is equal to t
applied to each of those vectors and
summed up or we could take it the other
way t applied to two separate vectors so
that we could call this one vector right
here and this vector right here so in
this case i have a t applied to one
vector and i'm summing it to a t applied
to another vector so it's this right
here which we know is equal to
t
applied to the sum of those two vectors
so this is t applied to the vector t
inverse of a
let me write it here so this is going to
be equal to t inverse
of a
plus
t
inverse
of b it might look a little convoluted
but all i'm saying is look this looks
just like this
if you say that
if you say that x is equal to t inverse
of a and if you say that y is equal to t
inverse of b
so this looks just like that it's going
to be equal to the transformation t
applied to the sum of those two vectors
so it's going to equal the
transformation t applied to the inverse
of a
t inverse of a plus t inverse of b i
just use the fact that t is linear to
get here
now what can i do let me let me simplify
everything that i've written right here
so i now have
let me rewrite this this thing up here
which is the same thing as this t the
composition of t with t inverse
applied to a
plus b
applied to a plus b
is equal to
the composition or
actually not the composition just t
applied to two vectors
t inverse of a
plus t inverse
of vector b that's what we've gotten so
far
now we're very close to proving that
this condition is true for t inverse if
we can just get rid of these t's well
the best way to get rid of those t's is
apply to t is to take the composition
with t inverse on both sides or take the
t inverse transformation of both sides
of this equation so let's do that
so let's take t inverse of this side
t inverse of that side should be equal
to t inverse of this side
because these two things are the same
thing so if you put the same thing into
a function you should get the same value
on both sides
so what is this thing on the left hand
side
what is this this is the composition let
me write this way this is the
composition of t
inverse with t that part applied to
this thing right here
applied to i'm just changing the
associativity of this applied to
t inverse
of the vector a plus the vector b
that's what this left hand side is
this part right here t inverse of t
of this i'm just this first two steps
i'm just writing as a composition of t
inverse with t
applied to
applied to this right here that right
there is the same thing as that right
there so that was another way to write
that and so that is going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to the
composition of t inverse with t
it's already in the same color the
that's this part right here which is
very similar to that part right there of
of
this stuff right here
t inverse of a
plus t inverse
of the vector b
now by definition of what t inverse is
what is this
this is
this is the identity transformation on
our domain this is the identity
transformation on rn
this is also the identity transformation
on rn
so if you apply the identity
transformation to anything you're just
going to get anything so this is going
to be equal to
and i'll do it on both sides of the
equation
this is just going to this whole
expression on the left hand side is just
going to simplify to the t inverse of
the vectors a plus the vector b and the
right hand side is just going to
simplify to this thing
is equal to because this is just the
identity transformation so it's just
equal to this one t inverse of the
vector a
plus t inverse
of the vector b and just like that we've
met t inverse has met its first
condition for being a linear
transformation
it's met its first condition now let's
see if we can do the second condition
let's take
let's take t of
let's do the same type of thing let's
take the composition of
t
with t inverse
of
let's take the composition of that
on some vector let's call it
c a
just like that well we know what this is
equal to this is equal to the identity
transformation on rn so this is just
going to be equal to
c
a
now what is a equal to
what is a equal to
what is this thing right there equal
i'll write it on the side right here let
me do it in a appropriate color we could
say that a
the vector a is equal to
the transformation
t
with the composition of t with t inverse
t inverse applied to the vector a
because this is just the identity
transformation so we can rewrite this
expression here as being equal to c
times
the composition of
t
with t inverse
applied to
applied to my vector a and maybe it
might be nice to rewrite it in this in
this form instead of this composition
form so this left expression we can just
write as saying t of the t inverse of
c times the vector a all i did is
rewrite this left hand side this way is
equal to is equal to this green thing
right here well i'll rewrite similarly
this is equal to
c times
t
the transformation t applied to the
transformation
t inverse applied to a
this is by definition what composition
means this is what composition means
now t is a linear transformation t is a
linear transformation which means that
you can take that if you take c times t
times some vector that is equivalent to
t times c
times t applied to c times that vector
this is one of the conditions of a
linear transformation so this is always
going to be the case with t
so
this is some vector that t is applying
to this is some scalar so this thing
because we know that t is a linear
transformation
we can rewrite as being equal to
t applied to
the scalar c times t inverse
applied to a
and now what can we do
well let's apply the t inverse
transformation to both sides of this let
me rewrite it so on this side we get
t of
t inverse
of c a
is equal to
t of c times t inverse
times a
that's what we have so far and wouldn't
it be nice if we could get rid of these
outer t's and the best way to do that is
to take the inverse the t inverse
transformation of both sides
so let's do that
t inverse let's take that of both sides
of this equation
t
inverse
of both sides and another way that this
could be written
this is equivalent to t the composition
of t inverse with t
applied to
t inverse
applied to c times our vector a
this right here i've just
decided to keep writing it in this form
and i took these two guys out and i
wrote them as a composition and this on
the right hand side you can do something
very similar you could say that this is
equal to the composition of t inverse
with t
times or not times let me be very
careful uh taking this composition this
transformation and then taking that
transformation on
on
c
times
or c times the tren the inverse
transformation applied to a
let me very clear what i did here this
thing right here is this thing right
here this thing right here is this thing
right here and i just rewrote this
composition this way i rewrote this
composition this way and the reason why
i did this is because because we know
that this is just the identity
transformation on rn
and this is just the identity
so the identity transformation applied
to anything is just that anything so
this equation simplifies to
the n t inverse applied to c times some
vector a is equal to this thing
c times t inverse times some vector a
and just like that we've met our second
condition
or being a linear transformation
we've met our second condition the first
condition was met up here so now we know
and in both cases we use the fact that t
was a linear transformation to get to
the result for t inverse so now we know
that if t
if t is a linear transformation t is a
linear transformation
and t is
invertible
then
t inverse
is also
also a linear transformation
linear transformation
which might seem like a little nice
thing to know but that's actually a big
thing to know because now we know that t
inverse can be represented as a matrix
vector product so that means that t
inverse
applied to some vector x could be
represented as the product of some
matrix times x
and what we're going to do is we're
going to call that matrix
we're going to call that matrix the
matrix a
inverse and i haven't defined this well
how do you construct this a inverse
matrix but we know that it exists we
know this this exists now because t is a
linear transformation and we could take
it even a step further
we know by the definition of a of of
invertibility
that the composition of t inverse with t
is equal to the identity
transformation on r n the identity
transformation on r n
well what is the composition we know
that t if we take if we take let me put
it this way
we know that t of x
is equal to ax
so if we write t inverse the composition
of t inverse with t
applied to some vector x is going to be
equal to
first
ax a being applied to x so it's going to
be equal to ax this a right here
ax
and then you're going to apply a inverse
x you're going to apply this right here
and we got this that this is equivalent
to when you take the composition it's
equivalent to or the resulting the
resulting transformation matrix of two
composition transformations is equal to
this matrix matrix product we got that a
long time ago in fact that was the
motivation for how a matrix matrix
product was defined but what's
interesting here is this composition is
equal to that but it's also equal to
it's also going to be equal to the
identity transformation on rn
applied to that vector x which is equal
to the identity matrix the identity
matrix applied to x right that is the n
by n matrix that when you multiply it by
anything you get that anything again
so we get a very interesting result
a inverse times a
has to be equal to the identity matrix
a inverse or the matrix transformation
for t inverse when you multiply that
with the matrix transformation for t
you are going to get the identity matrix
and the argument actually holds both
ways
so we know this is true but the other
definition of an inverse or
invertibility told us that the
composition of t with t inverse is equal
to the identity transformation in our
codomain which is also rn
irn so by the exact same argument we
know that when you go the other way if
you apply t inverse first and then you
apply t
so that's the equivalent of saying you
apply t inverse first and then you apply
t
to some
x vector that's equivalent to
multiplying that x vector by the
identity matrix the n by n identity
matrix or you could say you could switch
the order a times a inverse
is also equal to the identity matrix
which is neat because we learned that
matrix matrix products when you switch
the order they don't normally always
equal each other but in the case of a of
an invertible matrix and it's inverse
order doesn't matter you can take a
inverse times a and get the identity
matrix or you could take a times a
inverse and get the identity matrix now
we've gotten this far the next step is
to actually figure out how do you
construct we know that this thing exists
we know that the inverse is linear
transformation that this matrix exists
we see this nice property that when you
multiply it times the transformation
matrix you get
the you get the identity matrix the next
step is to actually figure out how to
figure this this guy out